the hype behind eldon ring continues to
build as a release date draws near what
spoilers have already made their way
online keep watching if you're hungry
for every morsel of information about
this long-awaited game
during the game's closed network test
players with jailbroken ps4s datamined
old and ring and uncovered some closely
guarded secrets from software clearly
understood the risk of players digging
too deeply into the test run which is
why the developers placed a giant bear
in the game that would kill any players
who managed to find the way outside of
the test boundaries not too surprising
considering the developers enduring
sadistic tendencies but really though
after all the things dark souls players
have been through over the years is a
ferocious bear all that intimidating hey
ron i'm riding a furry tractor
unfortunately for from software the
developers couldn't predict this new ps4
exploit the verge released a report
about the ps4 jailbreak on december 14
2021 and spoilers for eldon ring began
making rounds just a few days later of
course until the game actually releases
from software could certainly make as
many changes as it wants to the leaked
material
the elden rings story trailer introduces
the basics of the game's backstory it
opens by revealing that the fall of the
world's demigods began with godwin the
golden's death newly leaked information
from the game however seems to reveal
that godwin is very much alive the
leagues show that godwin will actually
be the game's primary blacksmith and the
players will rely on his abilities to
upgrade their weapons similar to the
process in dark souls considering that
the game's trailer claimed that godwin
had died after the rune of death was
stolen how does he factor into the rest
of the game's story another audio file
features godwin quietly rambling about
the grail and his ability to smith
weapons the speech is in line with
characters from previous souls games who
lost their minds after taking part in
horrifying events for a very long time
i was trapped within the crystal golem
from my home i was taken
and banished to a plane of distortion
perhaps tragedy left godwin's minds
damaged even as his body lives on to
assist future travelers and maybe that's
why the trailer shows godwin's corpse
opening its eyes as black liquid oozes
from beneath its eyelids
one of the biggest changes that eldon
ring will introduce to the souls
sub-genre is an open world that puts a
heavy emphasis on exploration since the
first dark souls game from software has
been crafting wells that seamlessly
interlinked different areas but eldon
ring will offer an open world in the
more traditional sense in november 2021
bandai namco finally released a gameplay
preview of eldon ring that gave players
a taste of the variety of locations they
would encounter throughout the game the
recent data mining leagues have revealed
even more details about what's in store
for adventurers come february 2022 we
happy yeah we happy
one file that's been leaked makes
reference to the other eternal city the
speakers say that the city hides a
cradle chalice and though the importance
of the chalice has yet to be revealed
from software fans will likely remember
the importance of chalices in bloodborne
in that game chalices were used to
generate dungeons that could be explored
for unique loot and bosses some other
elder ring dialogue has been leaked in a
text file and an unknown speaker makes
reference to a secret path that leads
through a well to the meeting place of
the great caravan somewhere under the
capital secret paths and underground
cities are nothing new to veterans or
from software's previous games but we'll
have to wait until february or the next
round of leaks to piece together how the
great caravan fits into the game's story
from software's games tend to have
stories that are rich with details but
difficult to understand they're often
told through item descriptions and
opaque bits of dialogue threaded
throughout the game which turns piecing
things together into a challenging
mini-game of its own that makes this
particular leak especially exciting for
anyone who wants a deeper understanding
of elder ring's main story i
offer you an accord
datamined files from the game's closed
network tests contain an entire quest
worth of dialogue the dialogue comes
from millicent a young girl suffering
from scarlet rot and gauri the sage who
raised her milicent is the daughter of
melania who rules parts of the lands
between with her five sisters melania
once fought the giant lord radhan and
one day she will replace her mother
marika as queen gary asks that players
kill millerson from a lania ascends to
the throne only then will millicent
quote begin to flower and become a
scarlet valkyrie the branching dialogue
seems to reveal that players have the
option to either do as gary asks or to
help millicent escape her fate there's
no indication of how sensual this
particular quest line is to the main
story but fans already know from the
game's official description the queen
marika the eternal and her daughters are
a main focus
if the leaks are to be believed many fan
favorite methods of mowing down enemies
from the souls games will be returning
to eldon ring data mining has revealed
many of the various weapon classes that
the tarnish will have at their disposal
as they wonder about the lands between
slaying monsters many classes from the
great sword to the warhammer are soul
series regulars others like the bow and
crossbow have seen their mechanical ups
and downs over the years there are also
some exciting new additions including
the glintstone staff oh that is so
gnarly another returning combat
enhancement is the ability to infuse
weapons with various magical properties
or elements players can make their
blades ignite into flames poison enemies
or deal extreme physical damage for
anyone building a character with a
darker aim on dealing death blood and
occult infusions will likely work
perfectly though gamers don't yet have a
clear understanding of how they augment
damage there were no major surprises in
the weapons and infusions leak but there
are more than enough new touches to get
fan's imaginations running wild
the bosses of eldon ring will likely
provide some of the game's most
memorable moments
thy flame
let it be market the fell
there'll be no shortage of monstrous
death dealers for players to tackle
during their exploration of the lands
between but another spoiler claims to
reveal the identities of the six main
bosses who will need to be dispatched to
obtain the great runes players will take
on the golden lord godric the moonlord
ranala the bloodlord mogu the gracelord
morgot the chaos lord huralu and the
giant lord radon the last of these
intimidating warriors can be seen in the
game story trailer the elder ring
leagues uncovered a few other small
insights into two of the bosses there
are three nbc's listed as lord ranala's
children meaning that ronald's boss
battle could be one to look out for it
wouldn't be the first time from software
put players toe-to-toe with multiple
bosses in a single fight radar's
strength level is supported by another
audiophile where a female npc describes
his battle and victory with a
consolation of stars either she's
speaking metaphorically or radon is even
bigger than he appeared in the trailer
a massive text file containing huge
chunks of the game's dialogue was
uncovered during the data mining process
there are pages of text to pour over but
none of them label which characters are
speaking which lines even without that
key information however keen readers
have been able to pull out some inferred
story beats from the file's disjointed
lines and luckily for anyone truly
committed to uncovering as much
information as possible another leak can
work as a helpful guide a list of every
npc in the game has been revealed and it
can tell players quite a lot about what
to expect throughout their time in the
lands between queen marika the various
lords and minnesotans all stand out
because their names come up more often
than others in the dialogue that's been
revealed so far characters with names
like the raider and talking corpses are
little more than interesting mysteries
at this point but others might be
familiar to souls fans get ready to say
hello to patches once again oh the
demons haven't got to you have they i'm
in luck the extensive mpc list is also a
reminder of the game's scale there are
over five dozen npcs named and it's hard
to say for sure that everyone has been
included
sometimes a soundtrack can tell a story
of its own music can make or break a
game's tone and the music of elder ring
has high standards to live up to half a
dozen soundtrack files have been leaked
and they give an instant sense of how
the game will feel in one track epic
coral swells create a grandiose but
unrelentingly eerie atmosphere another
track that sounds like it came straight
out of a bloody fight scene uses a
combination of chorus vocals and
rhythmic strings to build the tension
composer yuka kitamura's talents are on
full display in all of the music that
has been leaked so far it's no surprise
that kitamura also worked on the
soundtrack for bloodborne and clearly
the horror elements that inspired the
previous game's sound have been brought
into elden ring until bandai namco
releases more in-game footage or a
playable demo that's open to the public
listening to these tracks is the closest
fans can get to experiencing the game
first hand
you don't really need leaks to tell you
how elden ring ends after exploring
every inch of the lands between and
slaying countless monsters and foes it
will all come down to one last epic boss
battle dark souls had gwyn lord of
cinder while bloodborne had gay men
every souls game has its own memorable
final bus and there's no reason to
expect that elden ring would suddenly
abandon this integral piece of the tried
and true formula well i'm convinced for
all the information pulled from the
game's closed network test data miners
apparently came up empty on the question
of the game's true big bad instead of
giving a definitive answer fans have
surmised that there are several
different possibilities ranging from
queen marika the eternal to melania's
many daughters queen maraca might be the
obvious choice for a final bus since our
offspring rule the various regions of
the lands between but from software
isn't exactly known for making obvious
decisions with their stories for now the
final battle in eldon ring remains a
mystery but the leagues have definitely
given fans a few credible hints
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]